[Music]
and treat it with ecstasy news oh oh
submit about you I love tech time yeah
hey a researchers are conducting the
first-ever clinical trials using MDMA to
treat alcohol addiction then treat one
addiction with another one how does that
work yeah what's the thought process
behind these scientists and this college
called the Imperial College London they
are testing in order to become the
first-ever clinical study using MDMA to
treat alcoholism and the way the reason
why they want to use MDMA is because
they're saying that ecstasy helps it
really helps the patient open up with
their therapist so there's a combination
and it builds empathy it makes people
feel like a like my family dog let's
talk yes sir they're going to have the
control group is going to be twenty
patients and they're going to be
recruited through the recreational drug
and alcohol services in Bristol means
wait they have a recreational drug
services not be so funny if they stop
being alcoholics but now they need the
[ __ ] MDMA ecstasy they make sure the
MDMA with alcohol is going back and
forth yeah so they're going to be
recruiting heavy drinkers these are
people that drink up to five bottles a
day of wine a day yeah why these
patients have also relapsed into
alcoholism repeatedly after attempting
other forms of treatment so the
treatment process is first they're going
to go through a physical detox of
everything and then there goes you to
standard therapy sessions without the
drugs
with their therapist and then the third
part is when they're going to be given
the drug in a capsule form and then it's
going to be during to supervise
treatment sessions while they're talking
to the therapists we're going to be
having like an eye mask over their face
and they're going to be in quiet
meditation and then that will enable
them to open
that's not the right way to open them up
they need to do it the right way they
need to have five friends one of them
your show me your [ __ ] arms go
showing your back this year right here
one of them is like this and then you
bring the person up like that you have
four friends surrounding grabbing every
limb and massaging that and then you
have the therapist with the [ __ ] glow
stick and life on the eyes like this and
then you just pluck an airplane them and
you relax them out and then after that
you guys sit in a big [ __ ] like
circle and there's got to be some EDM
plane juice and you gotta give each
other light shows and then they're going
to open up I feel like every kid and
every one of the kind of drug before is
definitely going to us after watching
just we do the own stock is and these
men condoned the usage of drugs just to
let you guys know it was one of the best
times of my life but I don't condone the
usage of their right now all I'm saying
is when I was 14 sneaking out late at
night going to Ray's [ __ ] drop any
all night with my friends dancing all
[ __ ] night it was a great experience
but it's a horrible lifestyle so don't
do it but I was [ __ ] feeling good but
I don't think you guys should do it he
doesn't think you guys should you know I
really don't think right especially
right now everyone's doing like coke and
alcohol mixing that [ __ ] like back in
the day we did the safer [ __ ] like we're
just like dude
let's just drop a little E and you know
like maybe some acid and you know like
maybe some like weed to calm down
afterwards like we didn't do all this
crazy [ __ ] that kids are doing nowadays
it sounds the same you guys are so lucky
because I know a couple of homies right
now that did that [ __ ] so much the way
they speak now is false [ __ ] up dude
they could have been way smarter I
thought I could have been smarter we
speaks it's so [ __ ] slow now he was
never like that
he decided hey dude so you want a like
[ __ ] go out to eat or something it's
like damn bro what the [ __ ] I'm into
your brain oops like all fried and [ __ ]
damn maybe just maybe even more than you
guys did before you guys did a lot I did
a lot but then I also sobered up and I
like cleaned up pretty good
so like I did like I just quit cold
turkey and I just stopped it how long
were you doing it for probably in high
school I took like over a thousand pills
oh wait what are the negative side
effects of tangy [ __ ] bark thank you
yeah I don't know they said like holes
in the brain or something I just what I
remember feeling that I was able to like
to self-diagnose is like feeling
extremely melancholy for like two years
straight like no matter what I couldn't
be happy I probably was depressed like
clinically depressed probably I never
uses all the happy hormone yeah all you
exhaust all serotonin levels I think
that's why I started taking so much
because then to get the same feeling as
I did with one pill had to take like
eight and nine so so like my I got
really depressed and like every time I
hung out with the home is I just felt
like really dead and I just feel like as
happy as they are drinking but I gotta
pop some pills right now too so they
they drink and then I just pop pills and
then that's [ __ ] weird to like be
able to hang out I feel like and then so
I think I was probably depressed for two
years and then after that I think my
body slowly started to regulate itself
and my hormones came back I pictured
your circle of homies all drinking and
just talking about cars and girls and
you can stick in the corner was executed
at that's exactly what I was like there
I was like you wouldn't last I greatly
[ __ ] you talking about bro you're the
quarters [ __ ] trip it out surely one
of those side effects has something to
do with make your spinal fluid I don't
know that the or squishy like I don't
know about know one of the side effects
is a lot of dancing
I would like to do the real fantasizes
you need to buy shoes every week yeah
because you [ __ ] [ __ ] it's all
buttoned up you get black booger
syndrome you come home you blow your
nose and it's nothing but black [ __ ]
boogers anybody that's been to a massive
knows what the hell I'm talking about
everyone comes in looking like hot and
like all [ __ ] nice and [ __ ] by the
way by the time you go out everyone
looks like a [ __ ] mess
like they just survived the apocalypse
yeah like it's so funny because girls
will go and look at all pretty [ __ ] like
done up and by the middle of the night
you'll see like a group of girls like
triple areas oh yeah these are
alcoholics are going to be having those
faces as well while they're trying to so
they say that they're going to be ready
to start in two months
all right now they're just waiting for
the drug to be 99.99 percent
she works nothing off the pills that
you're on the street there's like just
[ __ ] there's methane there's like a
pile of crack a little bit of this
because like every single experience I
had was different I know some of them
make me chew like a [ __ ] some of
them make me dance like crazy and I
can't stop like my head is like just
rest right now dude triple pair comes
out we're just like the gravity of Earth
just got identified by like you can't
really carry your arm just stuck to the
floor to little feel like you're just
going down a roller coaster like this
and you just the whole time like ah
hi thank R&R sounds like a terrible
[ __ ] time well I went to school like
once a week and then I would like go to
Ray like three four times a week
yeah bad reasons for every every [ __ ]
week day there was an event there like
fun house with like Wednesday's right
fun house was Thursday's matrix
Wednesday matrix yeah there's like
there's one for every single master
don't Saturday's or Sun right at a
Saturday special is crazy vacuum but
don't do drugs it's [ __ ] horrible
shutters because like most people when
they talk about these stories they try
like to turn kids from any [ __ ] we are
but you guys are talking about it like
asthma Stahl Jake them all we did drugs
I'll admit we did drugs I actually think
this is going to work because I think
the people that are alcoholics is
probably trying to drink their sorrows
away and then it's hard to treat the
alcoholism if you don't know what pain
they're dealing with and for the
therapist to be able to open you up and
I do like the first two sober sessions
so you can kind of see what their mind
for something to tell you a while
they're sober and they're conscious and
then kind of like pry a little bit
deeper now you have information from
windows sober and when they open up and
you can tie everything together I like
that as people to open up the Chinese
water torture lean the backbone chair
put it all over the face and drop some
water in the face waterboarding tell me
your [ __ ] problems Beach about my
daddy never loved me I don't know about
treating one drug with another drug
because um when I sell weed this guy was
a meth head and he he would always call
me up at like 2:00 in the morning 3:00
in the mornings I can't speak right now
I can't sleep and I'm like that's
because you smoke in [ __ ] meth dude
you can't sleep I think the we idea
he doesn't even smoke weed that much but
then like you would just get weed to
like finally calm down and go to bed
and I'm just like damn dude that's so
sad but hey every week I could count on
him your badass custom how else would
you open up or how else would you make
someone super vulnerable and they
themselves don't even know regular
therapy well they are going this in
combination with regular therapy I think
it's a great idea though well you just
said it wasn't a good idea I don't think
you should make it a long-term thing at
once or twice let them drop a pill
massages temple
you open up like a [ __ ] maybe
they shouldn't tell them what they're
giving in like they shouldn't stay like
this is ecstasy likes it it's not easily
acceptable they should just all right
accessible other thing is MDMA which is
ingredient ah they should just say like
I like that it's pure it's not that
[ __ ] Street [ __ ] with [ __ ] all
kinds of like raiding in and stuff may I
want to have problems now a lot legal
MDMA and someone that just talked to me
alike but we kind of want to use it like
I want like for example like oxy is
supposed to be a drug that's used
medicinally but people use it for a
recreational drug as well yes really I
think really up to them to do that but
this is just that pure form of it it
helps with the therapeutic products more
pharmaceutical I guess it was supposed
to be MDMA was developed for people with
some type of autism or something like
that and I was supposed to be their
focus drug yeah it was like a psychology
based drug yeah help me focus it was
supposed to be some type of drug for I
don't know what it was specifically but
for people with like some kind of
condition what was the one uh when you
remember there's like a case study the
guy with the spike in his brain and
they're so he's extremely logical but
can't feel emotion yeah that's what I
was supposed to battle it helps build
empathy for people doubt no longer able
to empathize you can take and you all I
know what that feels like now like it
that's what I was supposed to help cure
yeah that's their main point in this to
like build empathy empathy also they're
saying that there was this us study that
show that 80% of the cases where
patients had advanced cancer and they
were suffering from depression and
anxiety
that's pictures that for sure well now
with that to see it wasn't it was cured
with the idea of ingredient in magic
mushrooms or silos an all right how are
you gonna prevent kids from doing drugs
and you call them [ __ ] magic
mushrooms I know that's ice Pharma sort
of law can we use a pharmaceutical
conference in the magic mushroom magic
mushrooms a lot of ancient cultures use
drugs as a way to like medicine yeah but
like we just see it as like the devil
doesn't the church like we should just
bring that [ __ ] back instead of taking
[ __ ] pills eat a [ __ ] mushroom eat it
was recently discovered
that magic mushrooms are the safest like
don't drug you to take a lifecycle down
I just like being myself yes I like
being sober now I don't like anything
that controls my trajection I say that
because you haven't seen some cool [ __ ]
you say that because you don't [ __ ]
do drugs no bottle but I don't even
listen to control and actually compare
but at the same time like you I have to
be like curious about it I'm not curious
you know actually drug David we should
dance
I'm not I'm not curious in a pot if I
was curious that's like like weed right
if I was curious enough to try I would
have maybe it will carry your clumsiness
that's impossible I really like my life
now and I don't really I'm not really
sorry
I like experiencing everything that I
have here well you just did a [ __ ] a
whole highschool block of drugs I think
you're fine
well I think it's like fun to reminisce
about the orgasms that you get every
single hair follicle that you can feel
but now I just like having normal stuff
you know what's sad is I only smoke weed
now hey you guys want to stock any of us
we'll go ahead down to the description
box below and you can follow us on
Instagram and all kinds of stuff for
more videos
[Music]
[Music]
you